Hey Chris.
>> Hey.
>> I got those burgers we
ordered from the restaurant.
>> Awesome, they look great.
>> Looks awesome.
>> I'm going to dig in here.
Wait a second, this doesn't
look like a Hawaiian burger.
Where's my runny egg?
>> Yeah and they kind of got
the wrong bun on mine, didn't they?
>> Dude, but did you tell them
what kind of burgers we ordered?
No, I just called and said,
I'd like two burgers to go, please.
And they said it'd be
ready in 15 minutes.
>> Dude, really?
You gotta be more specific.
>> I figured they'd just know.
We get the same thing every time.
Maybe I should've told them
who I was when I was ordering.
>> Yeah, you think?
Making an HTTP request is like
ordering a burger at a restaurant.
If you don't specifically order the
cheeseburger medium rare with a fried
egg, you might get a turkey
burger on sourdough instead.
>> Yeah, HTTP requests likewise
specify explicitly what content you're
looking for and
how you'd like it delivered.
>> In this next lesson, we'll talk
about how HTTP requests are used to get
the information that
we need over the web.
>> HTTP requests are a basic part of
how devices get information from other
computers on the Internet.
The idea is you ask for some
information, you get a response, and
then you extract the information
in a way that's useful.
Every time you visit a page like
Google.com on your computer
the web browser sends an HTP request
to the address that you entered.
It gets received by the computers
on the Internet that Google owns,
which process the request and create
a response to send back to your device.
Then the browser on your device
interprets the response and
updates the screen, which is the Google
home page that you probably recognize.
Now check this out, I'm going to give
you a little sneak peak into some neat
developer tools in
the Chrome web browser.
Feel free to try this out on your own.
To access Chrome's developer tools,
I'm going to activate contacts menu.
That's a right-click usually,
chose Inspect.
Now you can see Chrome developer tools
has a lot of information about each page
and how it's drawn.
It's got HTML CSS and
this stuff here, the Elements tab.
What we want is the Network tab,
the Network tab is going to show us
what loaded to create the webpage.
There is a lot of
different resources and
we'll see HTML, CSS,
JavaScript and images and
that sort of thing all getting loaded
into the page at the same time.
So let me do a refresh on this page, and
you can see all this files
just loaded themselves.
You can even see the timeline here of
how long it took for each one to load.
If I scroll up you can see here's
the main google.com resource that we got
with use to get method, to retrieve the
page and the status response was 200.
And it even tells us the size and
how long it took to retrieve the page.
And if I resize this window a bit so
I can see the content down here,
I can even see the request headers that
made up the request that came from my
device and
was sent to the Google servers.
Now the same communication and transfer
happens when you request data on
a mobile device whether it's the web
browser app viewing a website or
any other app using an API.
Apps can fetch data from some
remote source across the Internet,
such as computers owned by the USGS.
Let's explore HTTP in
a little more detail.
When we make an HTTP request,
we're basically including very specific
directions on what information we want
from another computer on a network.
In the request we include
a uniform resource olcator or
URL which is the address or location
of the data source that we want.
The URL tells us that we need to
communicate with computers at USGS as
opposed to the computers at Google or
any other organization.
A URL should look
pretty familiar to you.
It's a string of characters you type
into your web browser whenever you want
to visit a web page like google.com or
udacity.com.
Let's take a look at this example URL.
The first part is called the protocol or
scheme.
This is usually going to be http or
https.
The next part is called the host,
domain, or authority.
These all pretty much mean the same
thing, the main identity of the web
resource you're connecting to
like udacity.com or google.com.
The next part is the resource path.
This is analogous to a file or
folder structure on your computer, or
some other hierarchical
organization of information.
The final part is called the query.
The begin of the query is
indicated by the question mark.
The query is an optional way to include
information about things you're looking
for like search terms or
categories of information.